I'm so excited you're here
just watching your journey from
everything that's happening for you high
five because you are just changing
everything baking and you're breaking
barriers you're making the change making
bacon doing all it's just so exciting
what you see what's happening with you
and all of this having a late show I
mean congratulations thank you what does
that mean for you
honestly I've processed like 50% of the
world that I'm gonna dive into that's
gonna be a learning process exciting and
nerve-wracking at the same time so I'm
living through it honestly I'm just
living through it every single day and
it's very exciting for me did you know
this was gonna happen like like when I
was younger yeah was it a dream of yours
that this was this is what a Lilly Singh
was gonna do I mean I always wanted my
own show I wanted to be in movies happen
which I wanted to be in the
entertainment industry so badly you know
and I didn't know in what capacity or
specifically how so did I know I would
have my own late-night talk show No so I
don't even think young Lilly could have
dreamt that up to be honest that's what
this is cool about life but like I have
a ways to be like oh you didn't even
think of that one that's how my life is
and it's great you know what's so
amazing about you is the fact that you
used your voice for change and you just
continuously talk about different things
that you're going through and that's
what you a lot of people can connect
connect with you one of the things you
talked about was taking a break and that
was really important to a lot of people
yeah I know a lot of people have to meet
today I realized I was gonna have such
an impact no to be honest I didn't yeah
that's the thing with my life in general
though I just do things because it's
authentic ly what I'm feeling and I'm
talking about my experience and that's
what's beautiful about talking about
things then you quickly realize that
there's so many other people in the same
boat as you and you can have this
beautiful moment of connection that you
otherwise couldn't have and so I'm
trying to create more of those moments
now the comedy sketches will that be
part of your show yes I haven't told my
team I said listen the schedules and be
crazy but as much sketch comedy as we
can do needs to happen and also musical
sketch comedy needs a because I love
both of those things do you sing I rap
it's different I don't have a good voice
so I rap can we hear a little huh oh
yeah on YouTube
Oh
actually I got all my late-night shows
on your late-night joke maybe it's me
the last time I saw you was in Hawaii
for Jumanji and the rock was there I'm
glad that feels like forever that was a
long time ago that wasn't that long ago
was it was it I was like a year ago yeah
I think so yeah he's big part of your
life yeah he was he a mentor for you a
hundred percent I I would have put it a
post saying that when this opportunity
came to me there's two people I asked
for advice one was a sign Minaj and one
was Wayne Johnson there's only two
people and Dwayne's advice was great he
said listen if you want to become a
late-night host and then also act and
also do all these other things and you
will do that don't don't feel like
there's one specific path you have to
follow and he gave an example of himself
you know he was in wrestling first was a
football actually wrestling these are
acting in movies and TV shows he's
really created this path that is kind of
unparalleled and so he's like do the
same thing don't let people tell you
can't do one thing not the other I love
that so right after I hung up with him I
was like I'm gonna be late night do you
have time for yourself are you just cuz
it was a typical day for you a typical
day for me is not typical it's not like
it's just every day is different and I
love it every day is different I love it
and it's also a little stressful and the
best way possible you know because I
don't really know quick anecdote okay I
used to be so rigid with my schedule to
the point where I was like I'm traveling
here this is my flight was one month
away great and any time my flight would
have to change I would be stressed I'm
calling my sister what are the flight
change fees I refuse to pay 20 extra
dollars yes I can't do it and now my
schedule is to the point we're like if
I'm flying home tomorrow I could change
right now I probably over there changing
my flight and you're okay with it now
just come to terms yeah fact that my
days very fluid it's constantly changing
there's so many moving parts and that's
okay busy is a blessing we're gonna
accept this C is less I love that I'm
making more time for myself to answer
okay yeah okay I figured I have to I
have to be the best version of myself to
make sure that I put my all into this
show and that means not just you know in
terms of work it means mentally
spiritually emotionally all those things
mm-hmm and talking about traveling you
were just and I think it was in Delhi
that Priyanka got married Priyanka
Chopra it was in
not Billy was close to doing okay yeah
what's that for you it was amazing yeah
super amazing I mean it took an
estimated 84 years to get there truly is
all the flight yeah it was like three to
four flights and I was like whoo this is
gonna be a journey but it was so
wonderful I mean I adore her I adore
Nick there's such a great couple they're
so in love and it was so much fun yeah
and it's so nice to see you Mindy Kaling
we're seeing Priyanka Trump there's
there's a movement happening right now
and you're part of that what we're doing
it as you yeah kind of crazy that we
didn't have that growing yeah baby like
also I have to like practically think
about that sometimes because growing up
I watched a lot of Bollywood mhm and so
that's the only time I would see people
that look like me but I don't realize
until I actually think about the
implications of not seeing someone like
me in mainstream Hollywood you know and
so when people come up to me saying my
little sister gets to grow up seeing you
know that means a lot to me and I
recognize how important that is you know
and yesterday night I saw you at the
Raptors game yes my body is literally
breaking coming to these games I keep
coming back to watch again this is okay
I came back for a game last series as
well yeah I'm probably gonna come back
for Game five as well and it's you know
not a very short flight no it's not
you're a huge fan I know its history I
mean it doesn't like me I hope it's not
but this might be the only time in my
lifetime this happens and so I got a
support I listen I'm a proud from Tony
about Canadian Barack Obama was
variously you know you see him it felt
like Barack Barack Obama was there
because I've been in the building where
broca's there but it's always a
Security's a little extra special that
day so I knew it as soon as I walked in
I was like something's happening we're
so proud of you thank you to be Canadian
doing what you're doing is I want to say
thank you to you I look up to you as
well and to see your work ethics and I
think that's something I want my kids to
see as well so thank you for being you
know I'm [ __ ] and I you know I was
talking about this yesterday as well
the Canadian home town love is with
something really special for me really I
mean in LA everyone's been very
supportive but everyone's really busy
and there's a lot of noise and a lot of
hustle bus and I come home and just like
everyone from like when I land and
stones like sitting here with you
everyone's just I can feel the Canadian
love and it means so much to me yeah
even you're a late night show I mean the
people you're gonna be talking to is all
these girls are gonna be uplifted by and
so we're I'm gonna make it very very
known that I'm a Canadian yes poutine